every
person that wants to acquire success
should be up by 5 am
why because there's a lot there's a lot
to do and you need to get up early that
way you can take care of the the main
four in the morning so if you wake up
with that gratitude it shifts your
perspective and and with that
perspective now everything becomes an
opportunity instead of a challenge or a
problem now some people say what if I
work graveyard we're not talking about
the exception folks we're talking about
the norm okay the norm is you should be
getting your ass up early which means
technically if you're tired you've been
you'd probably want to get to bed a
little earlier but I think you should be
up at 5am and I think you should be you
know working on your existence your
family or whatever your goals are until
about seven and then and then I think
from 7 to 11 is is your family time and
then I think from you know 11 to 5 a.m
you're sleeping